geladas aren't afraid of all predators
you're looking at the Ethiopian wolf
this occurs in the glossa
and it's the rarest the rarest tainted
in the world there's only about 400
remaining in Ethiopia and 40 of them are
at Gua so their social but during the
day you see them mostly alone out
hunting for rodents back in 2008 Jeff
and I would often see seems like this
Ethiopian wolves stocking for rodents in
the middle of herds of geladas we didn't
really think much about it at the time
because we saw it so often we didn't
have very good cameras back then either
clearly years later after reading some
literature we realized that this was a
really weird thing to observe to observe
this carnivore in the middle of a herd
of monkeys and they're basically just
ignoring each other you know why isn't
the wolf going and grabbing a baby
gelada as a snack why isn't it getting
chased off by these monkeys so it seemed
like a phenomenon worthy of more study
so I wrote a grant to National
Geographic a young explorers grant and
in 2011 we had a reason and some money
to go back to Gaza so Jeff and I teamed
up again on this trip we followed wolves
around all day walking dozens of
kilometers a day and we watched the
behavior of these wolves when they were
with geladas and when they were alone so
we can make a comparison what we found
is that these wolves gain an important
benefit by the presence of the monkeys
so they spend more of their effort
foraging when they're near monkeys and
they also catch more rodents per unit
time but they can't do anything when
they're among the monkeys they have to
adhere to certain rules of engagement so
they can't move too fast they're not
allowed to run and if they get within
two or three meters of a monkey they get
chased off as far as we can tell the
monkeys don't get anything really
positive or negative out of this but
this is a very rare kind of mixed
species in our
to have a predator stalking among a
potential prey species peacefully
ignoring each other so we wrote up a
scientific paper about this submitted it
it was published in a journal of
homology and when the paper came out we
also got some press that really
surprised this our monkeys domesticating
wolves now this was really surprising
because we hadn't mentioned the D word
anywhere and I can tell you for a fact
that this is not occurring there we go
so as far as we know this kind of
interaction is actually unique to the
gua so it only happens at the glossa
this is because of the fragmented
species ranges of Ethiopian wolves and
geladas but we can suppose that in the
past maybe this interaction was more
widespread and some supporting evidence
for this comes from a mosaic it's 2,000
years old that you actually saw earlier
this mosaic depicts the Nile and toward
the top we have the origin of the Nile
in the Ethiopian highlands I'll direct
your attention to two sets of archers on
the left and then near the rocky
outcropping in the middle there so we
see on the left the stingy ax the Sphinx
monkey of earlier and on the right the
Ethiopian wolf so I think it's striking
that two thousand years ago artists were
portraying these species in the same
frame just like in Jeff's photographs
this highlights to me what's really
special about the Glossip it preserves
not only species diversity and genetic
diversity but a different kind of
diversity which is behavioral diversity
this is what allows animals to adapt to
changing conditions and that's really
important going into the 21st century
I was always frustrated coming back from
some of these trips trying to talk about
concepts like behavioural diversity or
just describing the scenes that I saw
and I dealt with this by turning towards
photography since 2008 in our crappy
camera technology we got some newer
cameras
a lot of time in the field and I found
this is a nice way to intersect my
scientific work with communicating this
work to other people and it's been a
very fruitful kind of collaboration
between these two ideas it's a great way
to improve the messaging of science but
many of the photos you've seen today are
end-products they don't start out like
this a photo for me often starts off as
an idea I see something and like I want
to capture the essence of that and we
can just kind of explore this in a very
simple example
I like watching geladas jump across
streams to me it's interesting it's a
cool like dynamic behavior and I wanted
to take a picture of it that just
captured the way I felt and you know I
tried and tried and tried and some of
these are interesting pictures perhaps
but they didn't quite connect and I ran
through trying an infrared camera you're
long exposures you know cutting geladas
heads off but when it comes to this to
get a nice picture it requires
persistence and for all of these is just
trial and trial and trial and mostly
failure eventually I end up with a
picture like this which is not a perfect
picture by any means but it's much
closer to the feeling that I wanted to
capture with the monkey jumping across
the stream so I've learned an immense
amount about photography by partnering
with other photographers I remember I
first came back from the monkey wolf
project the VOC and I were doing solely
as researchers and had the huge
collection of photographs and I was
showing them to a couple of people and I
met this guy Trevor frost and he took a
look at the pictures like oh that seems
like a pretty interesting place um have
you thought about trying to do a photo
essay event to kind of describe the
place in more detail like I have
thousands of pictures like it's already
a photo essay just pick a couple is like
I don't think you understand how this
works why don't we write a grant we
could go back together and try to mail
tell this story professionally it's like
wait they give you grants for
photography I had this very biologist
centric view of the world and so this
was illuminating for me so Trevor and I
wrote a grant and we were funded by
National Geographic to go try to capture
this environment so with the vet Korea
headed back to the field and Trevor
started teaching me some new techniques
like this camera trap setup where you
have a DSLR one of these big fancy
cameras with an infrared beam and if the
practice walking through triggering the
infrared beam to get it just right so
you can get a spectacular photo I
struggled at first initially um even
with opening the camera trap box I think
I stabbed my hand with my Leatherman
pretty good I was worried that was gonna
get infected but it wasn't so bad and
you know after just setting it up and
waiting and tweaking and tweaking
eventually we ended up with a photo like
this which was our tip staff bringing
their kids to work and they knew that we
set up an automatic camera machine and
they're like oh we can trigger this
camera anytime we want this is great so
they have their kids walk through it all
the time and then they would borrow
ak-47s from their neighbors and they'll
pull that out so we'll have a couple of
printouts for those guys when we head
back
but the real intention of this is to get
up close and personal with wildlife that
you couldn't otherwise to give you a
sense of their space in their
environment and this is the type of
picture that we were looking for an
Ethiopian wolf the rarest came in on the
planet in the glossa
so one day I had a happy intersection of
science and photography I was following
a wolf around trying to see if it would
have one of these monkey wolf
interactions to try to get a picture of
it when I saw a female walk off from the
gelada herd and this is bizarre behavior
sets off all sorts of alarm bells in my
biologist brain being like something's
happening what's going on
all right bailing on wolf I went over
and I watched her she started arching
her back and lying down and standing up
and I realized oh my god this monkey is
about to give birth so I gave her her
space with my telephoto lens I stepped
back in my shaking hands captured this
image sequence
so it's incredibly rare to see a primate
give birth in the wild I was very
excited about these images for aesthetic
purposes I thought it really spoke
visually to a process that most people
don't get to see but I also sensed that
there was great scientific value in
these images having talked to other
researchers that have worked at this
site before so it's kind of equally
excited about what this means to kind of
our broader understanding over the past
10 years scientists egg Wassa have
witnessed 15 live births which is the
largest or one of the largest catalogues
of live births in wild primates from
anywhere on the planet
we recent recently wrote up a paper kind
of describing this process and it's now
part of the scientific literature
looking at comparative process of birth
processes in primates the deck and I are
always trying to think of ways to
combine our photography with science
here's another National Geographic
funded project that we we came up with
it's a 3d imaging system that allows you
to capture the dimensions of wild living
primates without having to resort to any
invasive procedures basically you can
reconstruct a 3d version of what you're
looking at by taking multiple pictures
of the same thing from different angles
at the same time this is one of our
earlier versions we have a more complex
one built now and this is an active
project that we're still working on at
the moment but we have some promising
preliminary results and we're looking
forward to taking these kind of remote
measurements of morphology and combining
them with the long term behavioral data
set that we have at glossa it's a really
exciting intersection of photography and
science but this brings us towards the
end of our day on the high plateau the
Sun is starting to set in the West and
casts the huge shadow onto the rift
valley below and the farms that are down
there will walk with the go with the
geladas back towards their sleeping
cliffs and we'll leave them there it's a
routine that we do every day
we'll pick them up again in the morning
and they don't seem to really care
whether we're with them or not they just
go about their typical business and you
know we can hear this happening even
long after we've walked away hundreds of
meters back towards our camp you can
still hear them going about their
transition from day in tonight so
[Music]
tonight we've walked you through a day
in the life of gelato and the people who
study them we've shown you some science
and some intimate portraits of behaviors
that seem to appear nowhere else on
earth over the past few years I've grown
very appreciative of integrating science
and photography together to not only
discover something but then tell a story
about it whether it's through data and
statistics or through pictures Jeff and
I always love returning to the glossa
because in a lot of ways everything is
kind of the same we see some of the same
individuals the routine is more or less
the same year to year but the guava is
also changing and it's changing rapidly
today there's power lines and roads that
go through part of it connecting the
people living near the glossa with the
outside world and it's not only the
landscapes is changing but also the
perceptions of the local community
members picked also here he's worked for
our staff for seven or eight years now
and the truth is when he was a young kid
he hated geladas they raided his crops
and he would run after them with stones
and try to hit them but over the years
his perspective has changed he spent a
lot of hours with the monkeys and he's
watched their individual personalities
develop and these bonds between mothers
and infants
develop as well and he even tells us
that now when I see monkeys I see you
know what makes us human basically we've
also talked about the factors that
affect species and their ability to
persist in the 21st century geography
climate and the local community of
plants and animals and to that we can
add another element which is a human
community the Casa has persisted for 400
years across revolutions and famines all
because of local engagement of the
people with their land and of course
today we're facing a major conservation
crisis humans are shaping the natural
world like never before and a lot of
these problems have global solutions
like climate change but for others
perhaps the glossa provides a lesson
I think the Casa shows us that going
into the 21st century local small-scale
conservation has a major role to play
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]